ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi ci
appresteremo fare la ricetta più
suggerita nella storia di cucina buttata
ossia il sushi ora partiamo dal
presupposto che il sushi è una cosa
difficilissima da fare io non lo so fare
ecco perché abbiamo pensato di testare
uno strumento che teoricamente dovrebbe
permetterci di fare il sushi più
facilmente questo clistere per cavalli
dovrebbe funzionare qualora dovesse
funzionare sappiate che il link per
acquistarlo permetto qua sotto
indescrizioni in modo anche da
permettere tutte le persone che si
vogliono fare del male come facciamo noi
di provare a fare questa esperienza per
fare il sushi avremo bisogno di riso per
sushi alkhanov salmone abbattuto a
forcato un cetriolo philadelphia che no
arreda e basta questi ossessionato soia
semi di sesamo semi di papavero
teoricamente bisognerebbe usare laccetto
giapponese pazzesco e ne abbiamo trovato
l'aceto di mele e ce lo faremo andare
bene zucchero sale zenzero e passati
facciamo ordine
ok allora che ha grande
ok non sa come iniziamo a preparare il
riso prendiamo intanto una pentola
riempiamo un bicchiere più o meno ci
stiamo nel nostro caso abbiamo messo
tutto quanto il riso riempendo gli
obiettivi per un bicchiere di riso serve
un bicchiere e mezzo d'acqua
se il bicchiere un bicchierino 18 se la
tua tazza del cesso le proporzioni
rimangono sempre invariate andiamo a
pulirlo bisogna buttare l'acqua dentro
la casa caracas e poi come potete ben
vedere la cui uscita è piena di credo
sia mido e scoliamo la noi dobbiamo
continuare a fare questo procedimento
finché l'acqua non diventerà
perfettamente di ripida tocca farlo un
po di volte
una cosa e vi consiglio di fare cercate
di perder di tutti scolate questo che
facciamo è l'ultimo e poi ce la facciamo
andare bene a un certo punto l'acqua
sarà un pochino vedete più carina
a me va bene così mi sembra abbastanza
trasparente o bevuto acqua più brutta
abbiamo detto di aver usato due
bicchieri
adesso quindi né utilizzeremo 3 d acqua
da mettere nel riso quello che succederà
è che l'acqua evaporerà e nel momento in
cui come pure nell'acqua il riso sarà
pronta con l'uncem esatta che ovunque
prepariamo il condimento ed il riso
perché voi pensate che il riso del sushi
sì a riso e basta è presente quelli che
dicono tante solamente riso e pesce
crudo no non è così chiede di andare un
po a gusto 3 cucchiai abbondanti me
sembra tanto facciamo due fatti questo
che un momento applica ne possiamo di
carlo non sappiamo quale stiamo facendo
perché prima eravamo sul pezzo
io dire di aggiungere un cucchiaio di
zucchero un cucchiaino di sale scarso e
poi iniziò a tagliare ea preparare gli
ingredienti e trovare il salmone ha
battuto al supermercato è molto molto
difficile un modo per stare sicuri con
anisakis e roba varia è quello di
prendere al banco del pesce
il progetto di salmone
lo spin a te li togliete la pelle tracce
quello lì tagliato con lo spin a te tu
dov'eri e lo mettete nel freezer tre
giorni nel caso non lo facesse spiega
rischia di farsi molto male perché è
l'anisakis che rischi di prenderti con
parassita dicono non è un momento di
sensibilizzazione medica vi dico
semplicemente di non prenderlo si
capisce con sono preparatissimi
bello bravo creiamo delle striscette ok
abbiamo tagliato intanto il salmone a
passiamo a l'avvocato teoricamente uno
dei metodi che dicono è quello di
togliere il piru lino o sopra qualora
fosse verde molto molto chiaro allora
vuol dire che l'avvocato non è maturo
quando incomincia a diventare un verdone
scuro
l'avvocato sta a posto se è marrone
sappiate che se lo aprite e trovate il
triangolo delle bermuda pazzesco
io sento un'emozione che non deve andare
storto niente
randy cucchiaio stacca dai bordi ok e
poi passa sotto passa sotto passa sotto
passa sotto passa sopra passa sotto la
soglia della non è proprio pazzesco però
mamma mia
non so se resto la mossa no tu stavi
dormendo come al suo solito ma perché
mettere il cetriolo o singapore
a me sembra che non sia ancora cotton's
aggiungendo dell'acqua si perdonatemi il
metodo assorbimento non era perfetto per
favore di cottura assegniamo il secco io
no io in realtà di base a quello che
voglio fare è vedere su blister e
funziona potresti essere visto dai
giapponesi come noi abbiamo visto quello
della della carbonara ma sicuramente ti
poterlo spari direttamente in bocca se
non vuoi digerirlo da un'altra parte
gli stuntmen prendeva oddio forse sapete
cos'è che ho sbagliato
in realtà dovevo ottenerlo col coperchio
chiuso forse si può mai fare una cosa
tranquilla serena che ma dritta fino
alla fine vedi quant'acqua così esce
persa e adesso un bicchiere e mezzo ma
tenere chiuso puoi dirlo si sta già
cucinando di più sbagliato
ho sbagliato ed escluse tripoli ue mi
chiedo scusa ragazzi non volevo perdere
far chiedere quella della ricetta scusa
ragazza è la ricetta ma quindi casi uno
vede questo questo programma che
imparato a cucinare da morire ragazzi
anche perché ho capito pure come
funziona oddio se attaccato sotto
[Musica]
poco dai dai poco
aggiungiamo a questo punto ecco
appiccicoso vince voglio dire moltissimo
parate faccio proprio così agosto con i
danni insalata russa
vogliamo pensare che serva più zucchero
e per sale fidatevi di maniera
io conosco i miei polli peer è intanto
di raffreddarlo loro uso nel ventaglio
non von ce l'abbiamo ma mi raccomando
che ovviamente qua dentro ci stanno i
journey of time giratela come un
ventaglio fatto mi sento sì per
idratarmi rilasciato via l'acqua poi
venivano di bagnare le mani bagnate
perché se non si vuol dire scusa questo
su tutti è nessuno che sapesse questa
cosa ma io ho fatto un corso a salerno
c'è dividere quad hai le mani tele
sporchi tu io non ho manco lepre
istruzione di questa cosa ma è così
intuitivo che ce la posso fare
vai fallo tanto non ci interessa niente
[Applauso]
tu raffredda la tua lingua che mi sembra
che si stia muovendo troppo dentro la
tua bocca il rischio che non venga viso
dell'ordine di sushi mamma mia ragazzi
che bello poter lavorare con voi per le
iniezioni di ottimismo seguiamo
effettivamente il consiglio che ci è
stato dato a bagnarsi le mani e
appiattiamo 4 che abbiamo creato due
tunnel
prendiamo a questo punto il fascino caso
creato ma lei si sta facendo una doccia
sta lottando
contro l'acqua philadelphia la vedo un
po difficile spalmarla lo sai
quindi a questo punto si piazza
all'inizio qui che chiude a questo punto
col tappo sigilliamo e abitiamo qua
dentro
chi è ci vuole rubare sushi
no no no no no non verranno adesso a
mangiarsi col cazzo tom rea così
divertente
i recipienti pure sai cosa sarà anche di
legno breve la tua lingua dove è un
piatto allora lasciamo un attimo
riposare apriamo adesso farlo in maniera
diversa
o salmone esploderà ora mettiamo questo
facciamo andiamo sigilliamo loco sempre
meno compresso rispetto all'altro
turismo e appiccicoso come qualcosa di
sbagliato deve essere successo
la pillow che cosa sia mettendo sopra
qualora ne viste la parte non serve non
l'aveste riconosciuto e semi rinnovate
no
il primo lo yemen alla cessione andiamo
a taliani bagna il coltello e che l'ha
bagnata
clicca ma il design ha mosso la maglia
va proprio alla bagnata dita bagnate
sushi soddisfatto se le mele milioni
amici ne uscì no non c'è mai abitato
assunto vero specialmente se non ci miti
assistenti quindi un messaggio ma credo
che stia moderno con l'acqua per cento
veritiero sai che si parla di parlare in
giapponese
no dopo quella ragazzina
stiamo facendo un assaggio di questi
perché siccome ci studiamo guardavi del
velino giusto disco sembra avere una
consistenza frasi come lo sai
di più sarà infatti non è poco lavato
cioè paziente tavolo subito banditi gelo
che sta benissimo allora ragazzi
sembrano di x factor saggio polizia
senti diritti rimasti senza capitan one
d occhio agli schemi meritano almeno una
doccia modo per mangiare pure al tavolo
pavimenti sembrando luglio il termostato
specchio allora ragazzi siamo veramente
arrivati alla fine di quest'anno natura
questo sushi
il palato sito dimesso quando tutto
passato
il programma quindi ti sembra di sapere
in che modo male con il sushi se avete
notato qualcosa di differente non è
riuscita pure a farmi capire perché
questo visto che ce l'ha così tanto
google io come sempre vi invito a
scriverti a questo canale attivare
campagne e le notifiche qua sotto per
non perdere le prossime uscite
domenica prossima di un'altra puntata
ciao